you
[Music]
here we are celebrating the our favorite
unofficial national holiday it's
football Sunday baby welcome back to the
V our bedding show presented by the
Caesars Palace sports book this is our
bedding insider Kelly Stewart I'm cabby
Richardson Oh Kelly we got a lot of
protein in those picks this week so far
and flex on the tabie in case you guys
forgot we cache with my Reed Ravens plus
five and a half last week super awesome
backdoor cover by Lamar Jackson two and
one now on the season that Raider that
Redskins one still seen all right let's
go to our marquee matchup shall we
absolutely well actually before we get
to that some big news in the NFL Matthew
Stafford was battling a hip injury all
week he's expected to play he's active
now Kelly earlier did Stafford's
uncertainty affect the Kansas City
Chiefs and the Detroit Lions line you
know it looks like it did but it really
didn't Abbey bookmakers never took this
line down the six-and-a-half was there
but now seven here at Caesar's Palace
was actually up to seven and a half we
saw some Lions money come in but as far
as Stafford goes he looks like he's all
go the questionable thing didn't really
come into play just lots of Chiefs money
right so just remember I'm gonna be on
the Lions today yet again because why
the back door is open versus the Chiefs
defense always the look ahead line here
in Las Vegas was four and a half moved
up to six and a half now seven even
seven 1/2 why the line move because
again the bookmakers know they're gonna
get Chiefs money no matter what happens
next up another game that I like here
the redskins plus three at the Giants
total 48 and a half
careful of the side here guys this looks
like a total trap game to bet the Giants
and Daniel Jones home debut I know he
looked good against the Bucks
but be wary here Giants and skins D both
tied for 30th and points allowed for a
game I like the over 48 and a half it's
even 49 in some spots so I'm glad the
market agrees with me and last but not
least the Patriots - 7 at the bills
total 41 and a half Gaby I'm gonna do it
to you again you gotta wait till the end
of the show was
that's the best bed like that's I hate
that you make us make its way in the
current playoff format no teams that
have started a win three have made the
NFL playoffs and that makes me sad
because this season the people's parlay
is oh and three and each week the bleach
report audience votes on Twitter for
which three teams will place a $100 bet
on and we the people we can't focus on
the past we have to be optimistic about
our picks today which are the Chiefs
minus seven
the Patriots minus seven and the Cowboys
minus two and a half and if this sounds
like deja vu it's because those are the
same three teams god I I think it's
probably gonna be a one in two as I
mentioned last week guys all you have to
do is fade the peoples far away but all
three Street you're going to and one and
you're living on a yacht in the
Mediterranean like some of these guys
that we have on the show here no I'm
sorry guys I don't like any of those
picks but here are some I do like
heading off to Monday Night Football
the Bengals plus three and a half at the
Steelers total 45 I know the Steelers
have won eight straight but that was
with Ben Roethlisberger under center
I've been preaching hard about Andy
Dalton nine and two in September road
games against the spread guys were
catching a better quarterback here in a
divisional game plus the points Bengals
win this game
Raiders plus six and a half at the Colts
Colts over/under forty six and a half
I played the Raiders plus seven half so
I felt kind of guilty I gave this for my
producer early on in the week now down
to six and half which I like the line
move reverse line movement is always
something that ends up in my favor I
know the Colts three know against to
spread the season but we're gonna see
some regression with these high numbers
Raiders are scary to bet against are
averaging less than 13 points on the
road last season they're an ugly dog so
if you don't want to mess with them
there I really like this under again
they're being outscored on average of 15
points on the road under Gruden under 46
is my play here and last but not least
speaking of reverse line movement
Jaguars plus three now down to two and a
half at the Broncos total 37 and a half
I'm gonna surprise you guys I'm gonna
take a favorite whoa
getting crazy over here ugliest David on
the board of course Broncos thirteen to
one over last 14 home games in September
whoo Broncos are gonna finally get a W
with Vic Fangio we're gonna see Bradley
Chubb von Miller come to play you don't
like my side I also leaned towards the
under Jags have covered five of the last
six games towards younger and Broncos 12
straight but the Broncos is my favorite
play here wouldn't mind actually a
couple of Emmanuel Sanders touchdowns in
that Broncos game the best thing about
playing cards with your friends is the
bonding the camaraderie the competition
and if you win in poker you get the
friend you get to spend your friends
money as extravagantly as you want in
the beat in this week's betting
Confessional Santana Moss goes all-in in
poker against his Washington teammates
crazy stakes at this house for card game
that I played in Washington DC all
teammates of minds from the Redskins
Clinton Portis the Angelo all Carlos
Rogers which I had pocket aces at the
time I believe I bet all in ten stacks
of more I'm trying to get running guys
up out of the game surprisingly
everybody goes all-in with me when we
flipped our cars over I had pocket aces
the next guy had pocket jacks and then
this guy had pocket queens Portis
giggles and say man I should even be in
this game
this guy had suited to six I wonder why
he stayed in at the end of the game
probably like 40 to $50,000 left
quarters winning the game with a boat
some kind of way he's staying with the
to six and it matched up on the board
crazy game that's the kind of luck that
you see in movies
well played Clinton Portis I sent up the
by I got a car or have a really fun
weekend Las Vegas any ideas 50 grand in
Las Vegas I got a lot of ideas County
send us your buddy confessionals to be
featured on our social channel speaking
of which it is time for the minds of the
public or Kelly will answer vetting
questions sent to us from the police
report audience and up first Mel Reid
asks are there any torturing games
teasers that you like for this Sunday
yeah guys you got to be careful here
when betting teasers I only recommend
betting two teams six point teasers are
a dollar twenty here at Caesar's Palace
remember a teasers a multi leg bet that
allows you manipulate the spreads of
each game my favorite teaser this week
is the Vikings and the Saints I do
believe that Viking Stevens it's gonna
help keep it close with true Biscay on
the other side of the ball and on the
flipside Kirk Cousins liability it's
just a little bit less against that
monster bears defense the Saints I
actually like +2 two and a half so
getting them up over the key number of
seven here is awesome there now six out
of their last seven as a home underdog
villain man wants to know explain to the
newbies why you tease through the key
numbers yes this is very important
cabbie key numbers are three and seven
there aren't other numbers but these are
the most these are the ones that hit uh
and into the game
any margin of victory more than any
other 15% of NFL games land on the
three-point differential and 9% land on
a seven-point differential so here's my
Saints viking sea's were bumping through
the key numbers of three and seven
Vikings from one and a half to seven and
a half Saints two and a half to eight
and a half and don't forget most Caesars
guys lose so to get that extra hook is
really nice
I finally Ben Stillman wants to know
will the Texans old-line be able to keep
Watson upright long enough to win the
south I love the plus money in a media
taken yeah that plus money looks really
juicy here's the card off he has either
sports book to win the AFC South yet the
Texans wins 105 the Colts plus 220 the
jacks was 450 in the Titans plus 700 I
do agree with you I do like Indy plus
220 that's a hundred Olivette to win
$220 both sound are pretty easy schedule
outside of play in Kansas City and New
Orleans do you think they can split with
Houston they should win the division
before the season I bet the Jags plus
4/15 back to 450 was Gardner Minshew
mania I'm cheering hard for the Jags
here it's just not not this week
Cardinal issue is becoming a national
treasure like the moustache the headband
I can't with the diese have you seen
this photo with uncle Rico oh my god I
think uncle Rico could still sling it
over a mountain oh my gosh all right
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all there we go all right here is my
best bet of the season we catch last
week with the Ravens plus five and a
half and surprise surprise
I like another underdog I keep hearing
all these pundits for lack of better
words to say that they don't like the
they don't like the bills because they
haven't played anybody but neither of
the Patriots combined record of both
teams opponents as far as one in 17 yes
I'm buying the bills and the Josh Allen
Heights maybe Josh Allen more so because
his name is it Nathan Peterman if you
remember Nathan theater went through
that late pick six last year to cost the
bills to cover against the Pats cabbie
this line is downright disrespectful the
Bills first three-and-oh divisional home
dog catching seven points and
1999 vigor 99 and Buffalo Bills I think
of the Music City miracle it was magical
which kind of happened in 2000 but boy I
got one out oh okay all good I know it
having means we need another Music City
miracle in Buffalo to beat the Patriots
this week let's recap all of my picks
for week four these are listed in order
of confidence on how many units I would
recommend you bet on each so three units
on the bills plus seven I got so close
to making this a four unit play snow
sometimes you can't bet against Brady
and Belichick even if it is on the road
so I scaled it back a little bit two
units and all the other picks Kelly can
you explain one more time what a unit is
like how how much that is absolutely
it's a standard bet amount you typically
want one to five percent of your
bankroll so if I say three units I'd be
three percent of your bankroll so if I
had like a hundred bucks that I put
three dollars on on the bills to cover
that would be that's three percent of my
bankroll honey I mean your math is
correct but I hope you have more than
$100 Bancroft you're gambling I'm
working on it thank you for joining us
on the BR Betty show presented by the
Caesars Palace sports book our journey
continues on social at PR underscore
betting follow along Chuck my pics and
yours see you guys next week
[Music]
[Music]